it comes at night is probably my
favorite horror movie of the year so far
because of the psychological quandary
that the film poses questions like who
opened the door what is it is the ending
of the movie a dream or reality in this
video I'll be giving my interpretations
on some of the many ambiguities posed by
writer director Trey Edward Schultz who
I'll be referring to as Schulte for the
rest of this video for some reason just
for clarity's sake let's do a quick
recap of all the character names the
original family is led by Paul and his
wife is Sarah they have a teenage son
named Travis the guest family consists
of the father will who is married to Kim
and they have a young boy named Andrew
there will be spoilers ahead so if you
haven't seen the movie just pause this
video spend the next ninety seven
minutes watching it then unpause this
video ready go the end of the film is
driven by the introduction of the
sickness into the household this starts
one night when Travis is awake as he
often is to find the little boy Andrew
sleeping in the middle of the living
room he wakes him up and returned him to
his room where he crawls into bed with
his parents who don't seem to wake up as
Travis is returning to bed he hears
something in the house he approaches the
door and finds that it's partially open
with their dog who had run away earlier
dying on the floor
this of course causes panic and
finger-pointing from both families Paul
worries that Andrew wandered out and
caught the disease from the dog and he
uses the fact that Andrew was out of his
room as evidence to say he may be a
sleepwalker
will points out that Andrew can barely
even reached the door handles and
implies that Travis may have actually
been the one to open the door the
obvious flaw in that story is that we
know Andrew was out of his room so
unless somebody opened it for him it's
proof that he's able to reach the
doorknob but the possibility of it being
Travis still exists Kim knows he has
sleep issues and tends to wander around
after dark
due to their prior kitchen conversation
in the middle of the night Kim and will
both seem to be fairly innocent we can
see them sleeping while Travis brings
Andrew back to their room it's easy to
assume that Paul and Sarah would also be
asleep at this time and they would have
no reason to open the door and endanger
themselves like that after thinking
about it further
I don't think Sarah could really be
responsible because of her generally
non-malicious attitude I can however
come up with a reason that Paul might
have been the one
and Paul is very hostile towards will as
soon as they meet the only reason it
would seem that he even allows wool to
survive at first is that will mentions
the fact that he and his family have
food but no water
Paul formulates the plan to have them
move in use them to learn how to be more
self sustainable as we see in the scenes
with Travis learning from well before
framing them and killing them
in order to gain sole access to the
livestock while maintaining the trust of
his own family if that is his plan it is
a most devious one some might go so far
as to say that he lured will in using
the fire set at the beginning of the
movie to attract potential victims to
take advantage of however while this is
a possibility I don't think that's what
happened Paul knows about his son's
sleep issues and well I think he will do
immoral things to protect his family I
don't see him doing something that would
potentially put them in danger
especially so soon after having to put
down his own father I believe there is
another possibility so when they find
the dog he's lying inside the house so
he's out past the red door but not all
the way outside past the last door in
simpler terms if you compare their setup
to an airlock he's inside the airlock
meaning someone or something open the
door to let the dog in you might argue
that the doors were just accidentally
left open which already seems like an
unlikely possibility to me given how
seriously they take security but I think
the main factor that disproves this is
the symptoms of the dog the human
symptoms seem to include large boils
excessive perspiration and the excretion
of blood from the mouth the dog however
looks to have excessive bleeding and
from what I can see a huge gash on the
body and while we don't know how the
symptoms differ from animals to humans I
would say that it looks more like the
dog was attacked than disease so the
question becomes who attacked the dog in
the scene with dog runs away it's
basically left open-ended he runs off
seems to be barking at something then
goes out of sight and then suddenly just
stops barking you could make the case
that that's what it is
some kind of monster or mutant that
comes out at night to spread the disease
and while the idea of that is pretty
creepy it's almost less unsettling than
the alternative which is that other
humans have found out where they live
come into their house and killed their
dog to try to spread the disease to them
there's actually more evidence
for this theory than the monster theory
because when pollen will go to retrieve
wills family they're attacked by other
humans for seemingly no reason other
than possibly Jackson supplies while we
never find out the true intentions of
their aggression thanks in part to
Paul's overactive trigger finger we at
least know there are people out there in
the wilderness who want to kill Paul for
all we know they were already on their
way to kill Paul on his family when he
and will set out so based on all this
information we have I would theorize
that one of the Marauders from the wild
captured the dog infected it then dumped
it back in the house to try to destroy
the family with the hopes of later
driving them out and salvaging their
supplies when I first saw the movie in
theaters it ended the credits rolled and
the first thing I or anyone else in the
theatre said was so wait why is it
called it comes at night Schulte hasn't
given us an answer on that I'm gonna go
ahead and assume that he's not talking
about Stephen King's it or the it's that
follows people we already talked about
the possibility of there being some kind
of monster out there so let's further
explore those possibilities
I think the reactions of the dog are the
best evidence for the theory if there is
a creature out there that's probably
what's causing his animal instincts to
go on high alert it wouldn't be that
different from how animals seem to have
a sense for real predators or natural
disaster some say the animals and little
kids are somehow in closer wavelengths
to the paranormal and the two who seem
to freak out the most before that
fateful night are in fact the dog and
the child I personally don't think that
schultzy intended anything paranormal
going on though it could be more of a
metaphorical connotation could it be a
reference to the sickness that would
seem to make sense seeing is how we're
never given a proper name for this
disease and if you think about it all
the characters who have or seem to have
this illness
appear to get their symptom at night the
grandfather at the beginning of the
movie is put down at night and the dog
shows up dying at night Andrew starts
coughing and crying at night and of
course travis has both nightmares about
the sickness and the sickness itself
seems to come up at night
and while we're on the topic another
possibility is that it is supposed to
represent dreams or nightmares which
almost always come at night unless
you're me and you stay up making YouTube
videos instead I need sleep but if you
think about it dreams kind of make sense
because all the paranoia all the damage
to Travis's mental health ties back to
his dreams he can't sleep because his
nightmares are haunted by the sickness
his waking hours are all spent trying to
strengthen the family's protection
against the sickness in a way he has a
separate disease of his own the one that
lives in his head and also without him
being up and about at night they
probably never catch will and of course
he probably never contracts the disease
from either Andrew or the dog whichever
one of the two were the ones to transfer
it but above all of that I think that it
is something far scarier scarier than
some monster out in the wood scarier
than some crazy nomads competing for
resources scarier than a disease that is
wiped humanity to its brain what I'm
talking about
is fear itself when you think about it
and dig a little deeper fear and
paranoia are what drive all the suspense
in the entire film when will first
breaks into the house Travis and his
family here the unknown intruder
when Paul kills the Marauders in the
wild he does so out of fear the two
families drift apart and become paranoid
about what they don't know about each
other that out of fear and that turns
them against each other and they come to
fear each other it's also important to
think about what builds this fear most
of the suspense comes when the families
are locked away in their own rooms
discussing their lack of trust for the
other because of what they don't know
about each other's past discussing what
should be done with the other party
discussing morals and safety precautions
all due to fear of the unknown the
conversations
by nature take place in private after
the Sun has gone down from the safety of
their own bedrooms it comes at night
you may have noticed a couple of
opposing motifs in the movie and please
go ahead and let me know which ones
you've noticed in the comments I'm going
to talk about water and fire and what
they symbolize in the film water and
fire are opposites they cancel each
other out however they're both used for
the same purpose in it comes at night
cleansing at the beginning of the film
fire is used to cleanse the disease from
the house when they burn Travis's
grandfather the next step for their
family is to try to move on from their
loss and not long after will shows up
looking for supplies
Paul captures him and ties him to the
tree then waits it out to make sure he
doesn't have the sickness that's when
Paul makes his prisoner an offer he asks
him to tell the truth and in exchange he
will supply him with water so this is
the first example of somebody using
water to cleanse and achieve purity even
if it is less directly than other
examples throughout the film as Travis
struggles with nightmares of him
suffering from the sickness or
contracting the sickness he periodically
takes showers to try to not only
literally keep himself clean and disease
free but also to try to clear his mind
and hopefully help improve his situation
I would also say it's no coincidence
that the showerhead is so pathetic and
depressing and barely manages to keep
him covered similar to how his current
living situation is barely keeping him
covered keeping him alive we do end up
seeing Travis in the bathroom again
but this time there's no running water
on him just a black liquid running from
his nose the precautions that have been
taken didn't help
and now Paul will have to turn back to
the only cleansing solution that has
been known to work aspire I'm going to
explore this topic a little deeper in
the upcoming segment so just remember
what I said about the two opposite
elements being used for a similar
purpose
something that it comes at night does
differently than a lot of films is that
it remains objective about its
characters and allows the audience to
take sides based on what they see for
the most part we as the viewers are not
manipulated into choosing one side or
another except maybe by one fact which
is that we're introduced to Paul's
family first and meet them in the midst
of a tragedy the loss of a loved one
causing us to want to feel some
compassion for them for much of the
story
Travis seems to be our protagonist his
parents the allies however before the
end of the movie I was beginning to
question Paul and Sarah's morality in
the situation and had come to think that
they may be the real antagonists of the
story so let's take a step back and
analyze everything that's happened from
an analytical and psychological
standpoint Paul loses his father to the
disease and as a result becomes
extremely strict about the family's
routine and safety precautions we don't
really know anything that happens before
this only that the epidemic didn't take
place that long ago because Travis still
remembers what life was like before it
will breaks into the house and Paul
shows no mercy striking him down and
taking in prisoner at this point I'd
like to point out that the story isn't
necessarily told from Paul's point of
view both characters have unknown paths
which are occasionally talked about but
it's up to us to figure out if they're
lying
well played she'll sing a well played
next thing you know Paul is moving in
will and his family he doesn't really
give them much of an option given his
paranoia about having someone out there
in the world he knows where they are and
notice that they have resources so if we
can just run with the idea of will being
the protagonist then this is his
inciting incident this is what kicks the
story into motion for him on his way out
they're both attacks by Marauders but
eventually gain the upper hand Paul
finds himself in a position where he can
either bust a guy go or kill him will is
thinking logically and suggest that they
try to get some information out of him
but Paul just goes ahead and pulled the
trigger
this shows something about both of their
characters this also won't be the last
example of Paul withholding or avoiding
the release of information and as
someone who is supposedly a victim
behavior as such seems awfully
suspicious then to add to that one will
question him on it he becomes accusatory
and it's as if he's trying to shift
blame off of himself remember what I
said about water and fire let's continue
to analyze the story by framing the
characters as
elements will is water trying to cleanse
the world and do what's best for his
family in a logical non-destructive way
Paul is fire they'll burn through
anything to stay clean lives resources
pet friends and even family let's fast
forward a little bit to the part where
the dogs run gone first
Travis gives chase will takes off after
him and it wouldn't seem his intention
is to protect him from whatever happened
Paul on the other hand is just furious
at Travis for endangering himself like
that this could be an essential turning
point in the movie another potential
opportunity to learn more information
answers to questions like what got the
dog so riled up what lies beyond their
property and what got to the dog that
made it suddenly stop barking
Paul doesn't allow any of this to be
answered and he uses his dominant
position in the household to attract
both of them and cut off any chance of
learning more since his goal is to
protect his family he really could
benefit from such information and I
think this is the point in the story
where we'll start to have second
thoughts and starts to realize that Paul
may have good intentions as all good
anti-heroes do but he could be going
about it in a harmful way he's fire will
his water this key difference between
them continues to cause clash through
the climax of the film Andrew gets sick
and they both have different ways of
going about it
we'll just wants to leave and fend for
themselves out in the wild Paul is
uncompromising in its plan to kill
Andrew this part is told through Paul's
point of view in order to maintain the
suspense of the true condition andrew is
in most movies are told through the
protagonist but I just don't think that
that's the case here the guy goes on the
kill will then as Kym and Andrew are
clearly just terrified and trying to
escape he shoots them down as well it's
also heavily implied that he does the
same to his own son I'm not even trying
to suggest that he's entirely in the
wrong I think the best villains in
fiction have a good reason for what
they're doing and what makes them evil
is the way they go about it I think it's
reasonable to say that Paul is scarred
from what happened to him at the
beginning of the epidemic and these
scars have made him jaded and
unrelenting I feel like he's endured
something that anyone in his situation
would have the same reaction to
this theory is going to be a little
shorter and I don't necessarily think
that it's true but I'd like to bring it
up so we can open a discussion in the
comments which totally won't turn into a
shitstorm because the comments are such
a happy play but anyways what do you
guys think about the idea that when
Travis took Andrews hands
taken back the bed that he was infecting
the child not the other way around the
only evidence against it is that Andrew
gets his symptoms first but who knows
maybe something like that would show up
sooner in a child I also think it's
possible that Travis has actually had
the sickness for quite a while and it
first began to manifest itself as a
psychological attack which merely
precedes the physical symptoms that
would also explain why we hear Andrew
crying at night after he gets infected
before we ever see if he actually has
boils or anything again just some food
for thought or should I say putting
bread for thought
not much is known about what the disease
is actually supposed to be or what it's
supposed to represent we just have a
couple of small clues the first of which
is this painting shown at the outset I
researched it and found that it's called
the triumph of death by Pieter Bruegel
Schultz he actually talked about this
painting in an interview with birth
movies death link in the description
where he said the following
so I'd seen the timeless house I wanted
in the film and I saw that the family
should live in it but I wasn't quite
sure why and I had this book on Bruegel
and I stumbled on the triumph of death
painting and found out he made it during
the Black Death the bubonic plague and I
was just haunted by it this vision of
skeletons literally pulling people their
graves in a health gape I was drawn to
it
schultzy has also mentioned in several
interviews that this movie was
essentially been written at the time of
his father's death so this ended up
being a very personal piece for him his
dad died of cancer after a lot of
suffering so it would seem that all the
pain that comes to the victim and their
family during cancer treatment inspired
the effects of the disease in the movie
obviously cancer isn't contagious so I
see the fictional disease as a
combination of the effects of cancer
with some of the symptoms and
characteristics of the bubonic plague in
the 14th century
I was originally going to wrap it up
here but after surfing around the
internet and reading some reviews I
decided to cover one more theory the
idea that the dark ending was merely a
dream and that the true disease is
actually a mental disease and Travis is
being driven crazy by it
the theory proposes that his obsessive
paranoia with the disease causes him to
lose touch of what's real and what's not
a la Inception the theory is backed on
the presentation of the dream scenes in
comparison to the climactic scene the
dreams are all shot in anamorphic lenses
which basically give a camera much wider
angle of view making characters look
smaller and less significant the music
in the climax was also similar to the
dream sequences I like both of those
choices but I just don't think schultzy
was trying to say that this scene was a
literal nightmare I think it was more
along the lines of now your worst
nightmares have become reality this is
what it's like to live a nightmare I'm
basing this off of one thing and one
thing only the headspace of Trey Edward
Schultz writing this movie days after
losing his father he had to have had a
pretty dark outlook on life things
probably felt hopeless he probably felt
helpless living in a nightmare that he
knew he couldn't wake up from so if you
enjoyed this movie let's all show our
support to schultzy go ahead and like
this video if you'd be interested in
seeing him direct another horror film
and let's see how things stack up as for
me my name is Susie and I - direct
psychological horror movies among a few
other things check out these links to
see some of the stuff I do here on the
channel and if any of it looks
interesting to you
then go ahead and subscribe to see these
worlds for new Horrors every week you'll
also need to ring that death Bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]